Daniel Calvisi, story analyst, screenwriter, author:  In PULP FICTION
There's a moment where Bruce Willis character goes to buy some cigarettes and he says to the bartender he says
1 pack of red apples and the bartender says filters and he says none
And that's just a really cool
fast
interesting exchange there as opposed to 5 lines to explain what brand of cigarettes he wants and
Oh, you know what? How about no filters in those cigarettes, you know because it's very Noirish feel it's very
You know clipped and dark and tight and it's just filters none and that just gets the the idea across.
Jeffrey Davis, Screenwriter/Author: So Claude Rains in Casablanca says to Bogart. He says what what brought you to Casablanca and
Bogart says the waters and
And
It's a desert
And Booker says something like I was mistaken I was misinformed
I was missing
Which is great dialogue, just great dialogue
Music it's music. You know, which is the difference between
Speak like we're doing here. Author/Screenwriter, Peter Desberg: Except interesting dialogue.
good writing good script the scripts at command attention is
With an extraordinary capacity to engage your reader
And that's usually through really smart dialogue
The biggest problem with dialog is that writers often make it carry the burden of the story
When what you want to do is you want to tell the story visually, it's we're screenwriters not speaker writers
There's a reason for that so you want to tell the story visually and use the dialogue as icing on the cake once the dialogue
Doesn't have is that doesn't have the burden of telling the whole story. The dialogue can play can be fun
I mean, it's still giving us parts of the story, but it's not carrying the whole story. So
You know
If you look at if you watch a movie and look at a great movie often great movies have so much stuff
That is dialogue free
they're the
I
Think it's Billy Wilder who did this and the story goes to Billy Wilder who was a great German screenwriter
Came to the United States when the Nazis took over Germany and was sleeping on Peter. Laurie's couch like many screenwriters
Quentin Tarantino was
Sleeping on Scotty spiegel's couch and Scotty Spiegel got him a screenwriting job so that it could get him the hell off his couch
so Peter Lorre wanted to get Billy wild here the hell off his couch and
Hooked him up, but went to Paramount Pictures and pitched him as the greatest visual storytelling screenwriter
And so they had a scene and I want to say it's in dodsworth
but I could be wrong where it was a 10-page scene where a husband and wife have a
Argument and through the argument we find out that the their relationship is no longer
romantic or
Emotional in any way they're just two people that live in the same house
And so there's 10 pages of dialogue and they needed to cut it down and Billy Wilder turn that into a half page scene
And the half page scene was husband and wife on the elevator of their building
Husbands wearing his hat wife's got a purse clutched to her chest
Doors open pretty woman gets on the elevator husband takes off the hat and smiles at her, you know
And the wife basically takes a step away from the husband
that scene gives us pretty much all the information that the thrill is gone from this relationship without all that dialogue and
So always be looking for the scene that can demonstrate
What's going on in the story rather than tell us through dial
That doesn't mean you have to get rid of dialog but it does mean that
the dialog can now be something else can now have fun first thing you have to understand about dialog is that
It's got to be connected to the characters desire line in the scene
In other words if the character has an objective your intention in the scene
the dialogue has to match that intention and what I see a lot of times especially with exposition and information is
that a character is saying
All that information and you can tell that it's really the writers objective
in other words
The writer once tune wants the audience to know this information
because they think okay the audience needs to know this and this and this and this so the characters gonna say this in this in
this list and that doesn't work because
Scenes and dialogue are about a character's intention in the scene
everything a character says is
Matched to what that desire line is
So anything that doesn't belong to that doesn't fit and you can tell whether it's the writer wanting to that information
Wanting the audience not information whether it's part of the character
Good trick is to
Try and keep your sentences as short as possible
Which forces you to write in a punchy, er?
Fashion, that's that's something that that I guess I learned from my journalist father
Although honestly, I tend to break that rule a lot. So I'm probably a bit hypocritical there writers would constantly have
A great line at the end of a scene, but then they add a couple of more lines
There in security lines they call them. So we instantly just cross them out because they already had a great line
That's the end of the scene. And yes, everything hasn't been quite wrapped up
But that's that adds energy when you cut that you're pouring energy into the story when you leave it there
you're sucking energy out of the story because the audience is like bored through those last two lines and
Going or do we need that?
I was I'm out of it it you know you had me at a low kind of you know, you don't need that beginning
Sentence, you know, you're saying the same thing in repetition
two lines from now, you know, really getting concise down to the point of having or
Overriding where characters say something and you could say it would be better if they just had a reaction, you know
Always try to err on the side of let it let the actors act and emote rather than say something
you know if you see someone's eyes 60 feet on the screen that's gonna say a lot more than a
line of dialogue
You know so you cut cut cut cut cut cut they say cut the dialogue and then cut it 20% more than that
you're like, oh lean and no one wants to because but I've read screenplays that read like a stage play and you're like
That's not that's not what this is or scenes every director. I've worked with said give me something to shoot where the scene is
Just flattens and two people sitting that Quentin Tarantino can do it with the interesting dialogue with ten pages of dialogue
But two characters sitting in the dinner scene
You know the directors I worked with is they hate it. They're lazy. What are we doing?
It's just this this this you know, and plus the food would be spoiled
You know, it's it takes a long time to film it
You know
there's an old rule that you leave you enter a scene as late as possible and
You leave it as early as possible and you make sure that you hit the main
point of that scene and if you keep that in mind that will also tend to focus your
Dialogue cut to the chase what's going on, you know less is always more is you know what I mean? And
I've always found that
and you find
producer I worked with he caught the
Repetition and dialogue and I didn't even see it and he said you're saying the same thing here again. We don't need it
I'm like, oh my god, you're right, and he's a big
Anti repetition, you know
Producer and I've never had that before a producer like would point out those specifics like oh you're right
I've got this bad habit now of
Not even seeing it. And so now I'm very cognizant of that when I work with him and in general that
You know, we only have so much time
On the screen and so many pages and and if you don't like the constraints then write a novel
We can do whatever you want
but if you like the screenplay format, you know you have to have these dense packed scenes with subtext, but not
Go on for six eight pages, you know, there's a rhythm to it. You have a feel like you say when you start reading
That the scripts overwritten and you just know everything's described in the writers
So afraid to let go that their their vision or their ideas won't come through on the page
Well, once they take that script and make it. Yeah, but you want to
You know your imprint is the script
So, you know all these other little particulars are not going to help when it's overwritten
In listening to how real people talk
It doesn't mean you're transcribing it exactly, you know, people don't talk like they're in a movie
But so there is a certain amount of you know
dramatic license that you have to use but you can write to cinematically, you know, you can write to
theatrically into
Too much like your characters are on stage and that can come through on the page and that can really hurt your script
I mean what I do is I tend to be
the hero you
Know in in the first sharknado. I didn't know I am ziering was gonna play fin
So that character was just me. What would I do if I were thrown into this insane this situation?
And so then I I write as my ideal self
What would I like to say?
In in that situation, what would I like to do?
You know because in in everyday life we all have these moments where somebody says something to us, and we just go
and we don't know what to say and then ten minutes later it comes to you what you should have said to that person and
The beauty of screenwriting is you can wait ten minutes until you figure it out and then write it down
To write a good line of dialogue. Sometimes it'll take me three weeks and then ten drafts later
I'm still
Tweaking that that come back think about it as you have a fight with your friend and then you sit there in the shower kind
Of replaying that and you keep coming up. I should have said that like like that's what movies are that
They're the writer has gotten that perfect response. So you have this perfect
back-and-forth
Repartee that real life never has if any if people in real life talk the way they do in the movies
These will be crazy people
You know, but in the movies, it's okay
It's expected, you know in storytelling
so the idea of of everything being honed to
Be entertaining to be compelling to be a feast. It's it's a
Story is a feast as opposed to just running through the frigerator open the door and grab a few things
That's real life some of the keys to good dialog
people want to have now sounding dialogue the problem with natural sounding dialogue is if you were to go I
Took a class once where they said go record people in the wild
So I went to a mall and recorded people and what I got the most interesting thing
I got was a guy who spoke entirely in belches
And you can understand him but what happens in the war in the wild humans in the wild when we speak we talk and talk
And talk and never get to the point and that's a problem is in real life real dialogue seems to never go anywhere
So what we don't want is real dialogue we want
something that appears to be real dialogue and
that means we're gonna craft something so that it sounds real one of the ways to do that is to
have characters
misunderstand each other because bad dialogue in movies is when
Every character knows exactly what the other character is thinking when they say that in real life
We don't know what the other character is saying. So if you say
I'm sick of your job. I'm sick of you working your job. We may hear
I'm sick of you and respond to that we come up with our response sometimes before the end of the sentence so
Misunderstandings occur in real dialogue and we create that. I have a USA Network movie
Called hard evidence which is
Only memorable because it was released on video after showing on USA Network a million times on the same day as a Julia Roberts
movie called something to talk about both came out from Warner Brothers and my movie out rented it in the nation and
I have no idea why
except I did also see the Julie Roberts movie was wasn't all that hot but one of the things that happens in that script is
it's about a
Guy who cheats on his wife and while he's cheating on his wife
His mistress says she sells medical supplies, but actually what she is is a drug courier and in the course of the story
He she asked him to carry the gun to their meet because she usually goes with her boss and don't worry
My boss has been there a million times again. Although stays in the pocket never comes out
They go to meet do the exchange and the guy they meet pulls out a badge and says I'm with the DEA
You're busted and she says shoot him and he goes shoot him. I can't shoot him and
she
And basically she says he's just claiming his with the DA. It's not real shooting
and so she eventually helps the husband shoot the guy and then the husband has to go home to his wife and
pretend like nothing happened and
So he's not just covering up the mistress. He's now coming up the mistress and the murder
well, the wife thinks the husband's acting strange and decides to follow him and follows him as he goes to meet his mistress because he's
Freaked out about this whole thing
Goes to talk to the mistress about it because she's only when he can talk to he can't talk to his wife
so the wife sees the mistress puts two and two together and
Confronts the husband and says, you know, I know that you're sleep in her confronts the husband says I know what you did. He's like
Then she it's you're sleeping with this woman. He's like, oh
you know, it's only the mistress and so she basically says, you know
You're gonna sleep on the sofa from this point on or you know
We're breaking up. So he goes down they get into an argument. He sleeps on the
argument, he's he's the one that cheated so he's sleeping on the sofa and
the wife comes in one morning while he's in the kitchen and
Says this is after a period of time has passed and said that sofa can't be too comfortable
What does he think she means
He thinks she means
You can come up to the bedroom again. So he says so are you saying I can come up to the bedroom again?
That's his misunderstanding. She says no, I'm
Calling my lawyer. We're getting a divorce. You got to be out of here by sundown
so by creating that misunderstanding
It seems real
so think about how to create misunderstandings where one character hears things different or hears what they want to hear and
then they respond to what they want to hear and then they get the twist in there is the reality so
Dialogue can now play, you know
When you when it's not carrying the burden of the story dialogue can play dialogue can go down tangent places
Characters can say more amusing things
A lot is said with that being said at all. There's always that you know, and subtext is very important in your writing
so you're not just you know, you're not just
you you know, it's not just
The dialogue has like some depth to it and and what your exact what they're saying is not necessarily what they mean, you know
They're saying a to really mean B because they're there their intention to see you know
There's that so there are different layers to the to the dialogue and sometimes honestly
You don't know know about that until you write it and until you look look back on it and say wow
That was kind of interesting or like that speech didn't really go in the direction
I thought it would and yet it's kind of an interesting twist, you know
But you just try to make it real you try to make it the way
Real people interact in real situations if it's that kind of certainly it's that kind of movie. You can learn a lot about
how people speak
Just by sort of listening like listening in coffee shops to how people talk and stuff people rarely are very self-reflective
People rarely say exactly what they mean
people rarely talk in complete sentences, and so, you know
The words we choose when you think about
When you go to say something there's probably a hundred different ways. You could think of to say it
Why are you choosing the particular way you you choose and when you start to think like that?
And why your character is?
Choosing to say something that way and what they really don't want to reveal like why ye will they go to this length?
But they won't go just a little bit more vulnerable
When you kind of understand that about your character, then I think writing the dialogue becomes easier
But you have to put that thought process into it first to know what they want to conceal and what they want to to give
I
Think and then and then you can start working with the subtext and all that kind of stuff that makes all of that flavor
Kind of come out
subtext generated in probably two ways one is
if this topic of your scene is
Why are you cheating on me as it sometimes is say with harsh and Carol?
You have them talk about anything but that in a way and in a
Context so harsh and Carol
talking about their marriage whilst to res is in the other room and
Overhearing things you do it in that way. You you go off point of a conversation
You have a conversation about how difficult it is to repair the damn plumbing or whatever
But and you do that in order to make your point very clear, which is dammit. This is this is wrong
All of this is wrong and the other way
Which is really a one of my favorite ways is to just describe behavior in a certain context
So Carolyn Torres riding in a car
What is she looking at? What is she doing? What is this? What's what's actually going on?
And none of it has anything to do with
Why don't know camera angles or anything like that it's just about what's happening which is
the basis of all drama whether it's a screenplay or
or play
How people inhabit a space at a certain time
That's it. It seems almost laughably
simple or easy but
It
rarely makes it intact to a screen in the way that
that this has enhanced greatly by the
Me's own sin and and and the performances and everybody in every department just working to
preserve a fundamental truth about a piece of material
Ultimately, it is about a character
Wanting something, right?
Every story is about a character wants them wanting something and then facing a conflict to get it whether they get it or not
So
When they want something they have a desire
That desire is expressed through subtext if I want this glass of water. I'm going to take the action, right?
So the subtext is that you can infer I'm thirsty or I'm looking for some sort of like physical
Distraction to keep my hands busy or something like that
And the gulping is part of that too sure maybe there's I'm about to confront you on something
Yes, you know or I'm your boss or you know, whatever. I'm an
Ex-girlfriend me. There's just so many things and anything you're like, you know, yeah exactly. She's gonna say to me
So a lot of that is about interpreting. We we are guessing what a character wants from the behaviors. They're exhibiting
right
now the context is simply the
Worldview the situation they're dealing with right. So we're sitting in a room right now. We have we all have different objectives
and
So that this the when the character so the context is literally just like the plate that you're serving everything on
like I
compare it like visually it came up with the metaphor of
Creme brulee just use a visual metaphor where you've got the plate as the context and then you've got the brulee or the the creme
the cream
As the subtext and then the the top layer that's burned and scorched
brûléed is
The text. Oh, that's great
So the idea is basically what we're seeing is words
Right and those words often are in complete contradiction of actual intention
but in some way were interpreting those words as a
kind of behavior
So most of the time like for example, it's part of the reason when I'm writing
The last thing I do is write dialogue. That was another thing I learned from wrong media
You want to be able to?
Well do whatever you want, but for me
I like to have the characters intentions very clear and the conflict that they're gonna be facing very clear and
What we're constantly trying to do is there's this one
there's a one book called character and viewpoint where it talks about how essentially
you know, we're all like chimpanzees in the wild and
when they're in when they're in the jungle, and they sense that there's a threat they run away and
The first thing they do as soon as they feel like they're safe. The very first thing they do is they stop they turn around
See where the source of danger is
so that's when they're completely engaged the whole chimpanzee metaphor is basically that we're trying to
Interpret the intention of things that are around us. So we're we're we're projecting
What we think that person wants by the way, it's behaving
So we're trying to determine whether it's a threat or whether it's safe
Whether it's one on our side or against us that kind of thing. So ultimately what we're looking for with
like with with dialog is we're trying to see if we can believe them and
The most interesting characters are completely unaware of what's actually driving them. You know, like they're
the whole time like
Indiana Jones is going through all of these ridiculous
hoops
Not really like the whole time. We're wondering like why is he taking on these Nazis? Why is it being dragged by a chair?
Just so that like some something and make it into a museum
Ultimately, he has this really, you know stuff that
depends how deep you want to go with Indiana Jones, but
He has this kind of drive to it. It's genuinely emotionally upsetting to him that there would be some betrayal some
misrepresentation of the truth and
That's what's interesting is so like the whole time he's making all these really bold choices. You think he's kind of this glib sarcastic
professor but um
what he's really doing is
He's trying to unearth truth and he's trying like he's literally putting his body under all his brutality
because he wants to the truth to be revealed and
That's you know and every single choice, you know that because every single choice
Whether he admits it or not has led toward him exposing the truth for what it is
The other thing about good dialog is that it beats around the bush
nobody ever comes right out and says something instead what they do is they hint at things and
so that ends up being subtext and subtext is
Dialogue plus action. It's never only the dialogue usually dialogue plus action
so if I am sitting in a cinema seat and
There is a and ice then my de line of dialogue is can I sit here? Is that okay?
If I sit here that line of dialogue changes meanings if it's a gigantic huge, you know
Ex-convict with tattoos all over them or if it's an attractive member of the opposite sex
but the same line of dialogue has two different meanings there because of the situation and
one of the things you want to do is
Again, that's the dialogue is not carrying the story there
It's it's part of the visual and the verbal is a movie but characters often hint around two things
I never come right out and say them and that's good dialogue, too because if you think about
Characters as like I like to think about it, it's a first date you're on a first date
You aren't going to immediately ask so you ever been married you divorced instead
What you do is say well, you know, how do you feel about?
You know something that's that seems neutral and it's the neutral way to get the information
You ask questions like you never asked. So how do you feel about equal rights and responsibilities?
When really what you want to ask is you just ordered this lobster plate. It's gonna smacks up my credit card
would you could this be Dutch, you know, you sort of hint around it things and that's how people really
talk or at least that's what seems real on film as if characters don't come right out and say things if they hint around and
that again comes with once they hit around the audience either knows or does not know what the
Reality is and so we get either infirmity. We're learning information
From how they respond to the hints or we already know information that we're going they're trying to hide this this
Information we all have our hidden agendas. No matter what it is
If we're on the first date or hidden agenda is learning as much about that other person as we can
to figure out if there's gonna be a second date and
So we're always trying to feel out the situation
By sort of trying to find the neutral question that gives us the information if possible
So we may not come up with a direct question. We'll find the indirect way to find that information
So that's like a subtext element thing
Take a simple line. Go ahead. Drink it, right
So go ahead drink it is the text. Okay
We can add different subtext to it. So
if I say
Drink it
There's a different subtext, I'm sure maybe threatening you right
I say go ahead drink it right I'm saying I don't really care what you do if I say, go ahead
Fucking drink it right. I change the text a little bit, but the subtext is totally different
Now so that's text than subtext
context is
We're sitting in a bus
I'm holding a gun. This is a clumsy way. I'm holding a gun and you're holding poison, and I'm holding your child
So now the context is extremely loaded and
The choice that you're about to make is implicit and I'm saying if you don't drink it, I'm gonna shoot your baby
So I say go ahead drink it
See the context is this story? The context is a situation you're dealing with
We can come up with a much better. That's just that comes in
my head kinda makes it but the idea is that basically like the text is the
Ironically because writers tend to overemphasize dialogues so much the text tends to get too much importance
The most important stuff is the context and the subtext
because
The subtext is the intention the context is the conflict that you're dealing with the situation you're trying to deal with so if
we're in space and
we're flying toward the moon and
We know that
gravity
I don't know as we go if we're flying toward the moon and we know that this is
that the only thing that's going to save us is
This little serum and it could either boil our blood or it might save our lives and
We've just given up and we've been through this whole journey and we were about to open the hatch and I say go ahead
Drink it then. We open the hatch
It totally changes the whole context
So that the context is about the situation you're dealing with subtext is intention texts is just the artifacts
It's one expression of that desire
Finding the character's voice, you know
One of the mistakes a lot of screenwriters make is that they all the all the characters sound exactly alike
Well, you want each character to sound unique to themselves, you know
ideally
If you covered up the character's name and read the line you would be able to tell that it was that specific
Character because they should have a specific voice
another thing about dialogue is
think about how dialogue is character based it all comes from characters and if you take a
different group of people and have them say things they're gonna say it in different ways and
One of the things that I always use as my example is I write a lot in Starbucks coffee shops
Where all the baristas are dressed the same?
They all have the same basic dialogue. What will you be having room for cream, etc
But each one is an individual and the spin they put on it
their attitude comes out through the way they say things so there is a
Barista at one of my Starbucks who puts the positive spin on everything
So if you come in and say I lost my job today, she'll say great you can spend more time with your family
No matter how bad your life is
She puts the positive spin on everything and she is so upbeat and chipper that I just want to kill her
But but that's her spin. There is a barista who everything is about himself
so if you come up and say I want you know, the
Tea with two shots of melon, he goes melons not very good
I like the berry syrup the berry syrups better with this drink and it's like how is Howard's this has become about you
No matter what you say he turns it into his story. And so there are carry
These are these Opie all these people have the same dialogue the same basic dialogue, but how they say it
Well, they're spin they put on it
It shows their character through you know
The same basic dialogue but the spin on it and so think about character
think about dialogue as being the extension of character and how we're gonna learn about that character through however, they say they're you know,
The generic line is this now our job as writers is to take the generic line and do the specific to character line
You know this character thinks this this character
Believes that everything is sexual if you know what I mean, you know
and there's that barista the does that there's the barista that you know
No matter what you the opposite of the pepper, you know, whatever no matter what you do. It's always a terrible day for them
There's the there's the barista that thinks that everyone's out to get them. It's the paranoid barista
It's like, you know, so you know, why are you asking about whether we have you know?
And it's like all these are different characters and they come out through basically the same pieces of dialogue set in different ways
So think about how the character comes out through dialogue and that makes it individual and and interesting
You know the instead of saying the normal line, we now have the little spin on the line
Which makes it a better line of dialogue?
hopefully you created a
Unique enough character or a character with an with a strong enough
sense of who they are or what they're you know how you would describe that character and what their journey is gonna be
Emotional journey is going to be that the words kind of they kind of they don't write themselves necessarily
but they but but it's it's like the track that the train is running on so so, you know you you know
What the characters about you know where they're gonna go, you know what they're doing, right? You know what they're doing wrong and and and
What you want them to be and how they talk needs to match that
Basis of who they are if you get the note that all your characters sound the same first of all
you get a look at the attitude the other things to look at are things like characters vocabulary because
You don't want all of your characters to have the same vocabulary that you do each each character has different words for things
Common words are the main thing to look at character says yes, no
Right wrong all the words that pop up again and again and you need to find the individual way for each character to say things
So one character might say no another character might say nope. No siree, and these things are getting character related
You look at the character go how would this character say? No, and
What I usually do is I'll generate a list of yes knows Truffaut any words is gonna pop up again again
And then find the one that is that character and go okay. He's saying it this way
This also comes up with curse words. Can I curse in this? Oh, you may awesome
so
Curse words are one of those things I found of my favorite curse word is shit
Because I wrote a script and then when I was reading through it
I found out that when or anything goes wrong with any of my characters
They open their mouths and shit comes out. And so I thought that's not possible. They can't all beat me
So what I wanted to do is individualize their curse words
So I went through the script and found different ways for them to curse and each character had their own distinctive curse
and when I came to one of the characters name was Carter I
Just off the top of my head came up with Kitty crap
That's just kiddy crap
And when I used kitty crap
I went this now changes that character into something even better than it was
So I went back and made him he was a surfer dude, and now I made him a southern surfer, dude
Which I don't think I've ever seen on screen. And so now he has sort of these weird
phrases that are like, you know
Down-home phrases and surfer language all at once and so I thought that makes us a totally individual character
But word choice is one of those things where we each have our different vocabulary. And so that's gonna come out another thing about
Dialogue is that we all speak differently
there are characters that you know put in a word like, you know every few words, you know, and
Like I don't know like and those things which you use a little sparingly, but nonetheless
Create a different rhythm for that character
If you look at Yoda Yoda is the most messed up
sentence structure ever because he speaks backwards, but he speaks backwards and there's you know
there's memes that are like Yoda memes that have like the backwards Yoda talk and
That's such a distinctive type of dialogue if you can come up with dialogue like that
There will be people that will write that stuff and you'll know it's Yoda right away
and that's what you want to do is basically come up with dialogue that has a
sentence structure kind of a thing
Use of like pet words like like or you know or whatever
a different vocabulary for common words and also different vocabulary maybe
education has has differences one of the things I love about Elmore Leonard novels is
He takes guys who've done a lot of time in prison and they read in prison
So they have vocabularies that are much better than any of the cops because they've had a lot of time to do some reading
So he has these characters who have just like amazing
Vocabularies who are crooks which makes them interesting characters
But it makes sense because you know a lot of prison time to read
so again
Their vocabularies are better than the cops the thing that I love about
When you're reading at Elmore Leonard novel is when he goes to a character the description part is written in that characters voice
So he just jumps into that character and you're already seeing the world through that character's eyes before we get to
Them speaking and it already is in their voice. I don't know what that has to do with anything, but it's cool
If you watched
Justified there's there's a great example of an educated criminal because that guy you know
Is the smartest cleverest again clever a criminal thing, you know, but he's he's he's smart
He's clever he can i'll
talk people with his
Amazing vocabulary, which is better than mine with it, which is another thing when you're the writer
You don't have to have you know, all these words. You just have to know how to look them up
I like to talk a lot about contrast. So we have two characters in the scene. It's really always more interesting if the characters are
Contrasted. So if a character is speaking in a formal way so somebody was an academic or a professor or doctor a nice piece in
a formal way make sure that the person that he's
Interacting with speaks in a more slangy way or you know more contracted way because that's gonna make you're gonna create that contrast
You know just like in painting if you you want to highlight the color blue you surround it with yellow right? It's opposite
So it's the same thing with characters a lot of the techniques in in the dialogue chapter in the book are about individuality
How do you create individual voices cuz having all the characters sound the same is a very common problem with dialogue
it's usually the writers voice and you know, and
You know Sorkin has actually
Been criticized for that that all these characters sound the same
But you know when I when I talk about his dialogue and I show clips and actual scripts you can show that you know
He actually does
individualize and the characters sound different so it's an unfair criticism, but
but you have to do that, you know it helps if if there's some, you know difference in in character speech or cadence or
Contractions versus
You know
stilted writing grammatically correct training
I think what you always want to look for as a writer is if you've got two or more characters in the scene
You want to create a situation where they want opposing things or or?
Because otherwise, there's no conflict or one way to look at it is every scene is a power grab
Everybody wants to take control of the situation in what way that means to them. And so, how are they?
sort of
Secretly jockeying for position, you know, like he and I do like which of us. We're all just worried
We're worried about which of us looks smarter. See that's what this whole interview has been the other thing that
You said about the quite the the desires on the part of the character?
I was thinking I know you said there's a lot more than two. But two more I would think about as the writer
Besides
What were the two you said? What does the character well know that the two different objectives. Yeah
Basically what I broke it down to Michael is what I call the public
Objective right in other words if I asked fact anybody in this room now, what what are you doing here? What do you want?
What's your objective right now? We could talk about we're doing this interview. That's our public objective
Then there's underneath a deep underneath is a private objective which may not even be recognized
Well, yeah, that's what I was it may be in the unconscious. What's driving?
that
character to
Try to do that right and one way I would look at it. It's not quite the same as a desire is to ask
What is the character hiding from the other person?
Consciously. What is she hiding from him? And what is she hiding from herself?
what's the thing that she's not yet aware of that is really driving her and
You know underneath especially in the first half or 3/4 of the movie towards the end
you'd hoped that all that would come to the surface but
Deception and secrecy are very very powerful in telling a story
Because they add a whole new layer of conflict they get into this inner journey stuff
And they'll and the more conflict on the more layers the more you're gonna pull in your audience. That's good
I like the hiding thing. I
See because I was into that. Yeah, there's subconscious or the unconscious or the, you know, unaware of but the hiding and
Deception is secrecy. That's great. I'm gonna steal that can I steal the oh sure. I'll get yours. Thank you
No, I'll you can still use it. I mean I've got taking it forever. Okay, you want to share it?
You don't want to steal it. No, I'm not gonna stay. Yeah, I'm not gonna clear that my job is to look better
I'll give you credit for it. Okay, good. Okay, because we know my stated objective is to look smarter
I think we yes and I'm not trying and I'm trying to help you with I appreciate that. I'll help you think you're winning
Thank you. Let's move on. That was great. Let's move on
A lot of writers don't realize you know, they're so interested in story. And you know, how may I doing that?
You know not to to end it
Instead of thinking of how would this person express themselves in this situation to make me feel that I'm part of this scene
So that I could put myself in their place and feel what they're doing through the words
I would just add that that that is what drafting is for because if one draft you're gonna be focused on the story and
then
maybe when you've got the story you're gonna look at word choice and another draft and then you're gonna look at the dialogue and you
Know really polish the dialogue by and large you write a script you turn it in you get notes they'll and then then the notes
Come with dialogue issues. I don't understand this line. This isn't funnier love that line this works
This doesn't you know, could you add a little bit put a little twist on it? That's duplicated. You know that kind of thing
But which is very helpful and it's all like I look at the scripts
It's just this big piece of clay that you know, you're constantly molding and shaping and you know
It's just sort of moving with and trying to find the shape to it
And until you have your you know, the piece of pottery that you're trying to make
You know, it's it's a lot a lot of changes, you know, they always say they say the writing is rewriting, you know
And that's really you know, and that's so important. You know, I'm a big believer in rewriting
I'm fine about rewriting as long as it makes sense
And that it's not just to do it
To because you do make things better. You can't get it on one fell swoop
At least I can you know
you you have to write and rewrite and sort of really work on it and let think about it and get some distance from the
Material to you know, so that you can sort of look at it with your own fresh eyes
and you have a much better sense of what works and what doesn't work one of the
Best questions you can ask yourself for every single line of dialogue in your scene
So write the dialogue first draft just do what you want to do. Don't worry about
that but
When you reread the dialogue
Ask yourself for every line. Why is that character saying this? Why is the character saying that specific line?
Most of the time will be because they're responding to what so they're reacting to something. That's fine
but a
Lot of the times you will find that a character is saying something because you want the character to say that not because the character
Something in let's see another specific time
So you got to know what the character wants and then every line of dialogue is a strategy
For that character to get what they want and if that dialogue is not that then you rewrite the line until it fits that
In the 70s and 80s talk differently in the 90s and the lows, you know
I mean it it's it's over the four days of 50s. It's all very different but the basic community of communicating, you know
having clear
Interesting words that lead you to a particular point, that's always what you know it is it's how you get there
It's been a little bit different and writing anything. I've written. That's had a
Interest on I wrote a Christmas movie for Hallmark a few years ago and and there were flashbacks to the
1920s and I had a write dialogue that was
Seemed about right for the 1920s and it was just cadence, you know, it was just being a little bit more formal
You know a little bit more on the nose maybe with some of the things that were said and it was fine
You know, and it's just I think it worked
You know, I mean it wasn't about using is using going back and saying now
What word did they use in the 1920s for you know automobile, you know
It was something I mean
It wasn't that it was just it was a feeling it was a texture to the words so that can be really fun
You know because we don't know exactly know how people talked
I mean, yes, we have movies from back then and we can see but we're still filtering those things through it through a contemporary perspective
so it's not gonna be quite like it was back then and
You want people to be able to relate to it and understand it as a guy with gray in my hair?
You know, one of the problems often is is my vocabulary is different than current, you know
15 to 25 year old vocabulary and so part of that is you kind of have to
Remain a little current into what's going on in the world
and you know listen to slang that there's there's two theories on slang and one is to basically keep current with what's
How people are speaking which whether that is actually going down to the mall with your two people go to a mall anymore
That's probably that's dated right there
So, but anyway go down to wherever the young people go into your skate park
You know and record people and figure out what the slang is or the other way to do it is the clueless
Version where you create your own slang because that way if you create slang for today for today's youth
Then that film slang doesn't work in for tomorrow's youth its jeepers, you know
It's like, you know
it doesn't work but clueless decided that they were gonna take they were gonna create their own slang so that it would be
Even though it doesn't really work cuz that's he's totally Baldwin now has no meaning whatsoever
But basically they created their own
Slang for that movie and by creating their own slang. They came up with something that we hadn't heard before
so that also made it more interesting dialogue, but really you if you're if you're a writer and you're writing for
Today's audience. You have to sort of it still
Still know what today's audience sounds like and that deals with stories as well. Just the story concepts because
You know
It's like I I know a writer who's my age who is still writing movies for Julie Andrews and and that's never gonna happen
It's like you can write you can write for the past in the past unless you have a time machine
You can't sell that script for me
I grew up watching 70s movies and gritty 70s movies are great, but I don't own a time machine
I can't go if I wrote one. I can't really go back and sell it
So even though I still might write one of those just for my own personal
You know
Those are tough sales
They're they do everyone. So well pop through and I think part of that ends up being there based on a novel so you
Lose it
Killing me softly what the hell is the name know that there's a Brad Pitt movie?
My memories all gone, but there's like a seventh there was a recent 70s film. That was somehow made today
And it was a crime film. It was totally hit the gritty feel at the you know
The same sort of a 70s feel but those are so few and far between writing for the wrong time period is a mistake
Good dialog writers also have really good ears and
they're listening for the way people speak and
And they remember those sorts of things hearing things writing things down writing down expressions. Like oh my god. What a great expression
What does that mean? I'm gonna take that, you know or it just the dynamic between people, you know kinds of relationships
Who's talking to who at the supermarket listening to a couple arguing or?
Or being too nice to each other or whatever it is. You know, it's fascinating. I'm always writing things down listening to how people talk
Listening to interesting people
around how they talk and
Then once you write your dialogue
read it out loud, you know do a table read with friends or your writers group or
Just even if you read it out loud yourself
Listening to readings I find readings
incredibly valuable workshopping
And films and TV should be done the same way
Actors are not shy about telling you what doesn't work for them. Just like singers are not shy about telling a songwriter
Hey, you know when I land on that, it doesn't go the words don't go with the notes
Sort of a simple answer to your question though is read your dialogue aloud. Yes, very good point
And I don't know you can start using a world that that's not
Coming off my tongue very easily. I don't think I want to ask somebody to say that you know
When composers compose and you're writing for an orchestra?
and you don't know how to play the French horn and you can't play the oboe and
Quite often after it's done. You have people play through the parts and they say that's unplayable
You can't finger it that way and they have to go back and they have to change their parts
Because they're not writing for that instrument right now where we're reading through the play
We might directors dividing the play into beads and sections and and we're really focusing on yeah after we've read through it all together
Now we're focusing on the individual words and to see exactly what's working. And you know, what what words really don't quite make sense
So what what did I have in my mind that the actresses aren't necessarily
Feeling or getting or they don't quite know how to say it or the director isn't sure and that's an amazing process
You know, it's like a fantastic process. So being able to hone the words
It's kind of rare, you know, dude just it just only a table read of your script before something is produced
Which doesn't always happen is really really helpful. You have to hear other voices of the ones in your head
You know, you have to hear them say the words have actors read it out loud
I mean, they don't have to be professional actors, but just you and a friend read it out loud. Listen to how it flows
I think that can be really helpful people think for example that
Objectivity in the world exists, but it doesn't if if three people walk into this room
Would they all see the same thing? It's he chairs rug desk know
If an interior designer was to walk in this room, they would get nauseous
If a carpenter came in they'd be looking at the shelves plumb
If a psychologist came in they'd be looking at the titles of the books and if a chiropractor came in
They'd be looking at our posture and saying I see money coming my way
slouching but the the eye doesn't tell the brain what it sees the brain tells the eyes what to look for and
So they I didn't know that and so actors
Are constantly looking at when they're seeing any extreme and behavior. They're paying attention to the littlest things
You know, it's not just that his voice raises, but what's he doing with his hands while he's doing it?
how is this posture changed it's gonna use that and
So again the same thing good writers when they hear people talk
They're saying did that person get tongue-tied when she got really angry or did this whole slew of stuff?
just come rolling off the tongue and does this sound like something she said a lot of times or
Is this something that you know, is she saying it legato or staccato?
You know
It's like I'm so angry you I could just bust or is it I'm so angry at you
All right cook just bust and you all these things. They're listening for these things saying wow
Listen how the emotions coming out in every people doing stuff. That's the way I want to write the dialogue
So it's you look at what you're interested in
And if you're a good dialogue writer, you don't just think of what words they're gonna say
It's what have I seen people do when they're trying to demonstrate them when they're demonstrating that emotion
How do the words come out pay attention the world around you?
and you know, I something I watch I'll watch the movie or something on TV or whatever and and
I'll look at like the the the the run of dialogue who speak Manama phenomenal speech, you know, and it by
You know phenomenal piece of dial, you know
I loved the newsroom there and so I can show the HBO show and and you know, I would literally just like just
Look at it just play back over and over though certain sections of that show
And and the way that dialogue was constructed and you know
He's such a genius in terms of
Constructing dialogue and the word that he has is people use but you can learn so much from that
you can be so inspired and and then put your own voice into that kind of thing and again a lot of a lot of
writing dialogue is cadence and and personality and and things like that and
trying to have
Characters sound different, you know, so that not every character sounds exactly the same, you know
You give every character their own voice, which is tricky it's hard to do
But but that's that's also really important and you have to create a little bit of you have to create character
You know beneath, you know character that's that's kind of driving that dialogue for that. Even if it's just the you know about a
Supporting character somebody we don't see very much
But yeah, you kind of you got to pay attention to what's around you it's you know, the best things are out of reality
When you are doing a very contained like a low-budget
that has a lot to do with it too because a
Lot of times the people are sitting and talking right? You're in a room. You're in a house or whatever
So they're sitting and talking but I think making sure that that pacing is good
So it just doesn't feel like really, you know people just explaining things
that's kind of the death of people's dialogue is when people over explain and they don't know how to sort of weave in that that
exposition kind of nicely
Then it really just kind of like hangs there. That's that's not good writing. I think the biggest mistake is is over explaining and
not knowing
how to tunnel
The background of the story into the story instead of laying it out
Like we just developed a brilliant screenplay the last several years in which the opening conversation
Just is not convincing because there is no other
Explanation for the words in the conversation other than explaining to the audience what's going on?
And and that's a hard to avoid mistake because you know, you've got to explain what's going on
But if you do it overtly the audience is gonna not believe the dialogue
They're not going to believe, you know, they're gonna not be able to suspend their disbelief
so you have to sneak these things in to the story at times when they're needed and
Not too much too soon
one of the common mistake the the root mistake beneath that mistake is thinking that the audience is
Not as smart as they are. It's it's looking down on your audience. There's ways to make sure the exposition and your dialogue
matches the objective for example, if
if
you know, I'm
suspected of murder and you're you're the
You know detective who's asking me questions right and tell me where were you and I didn't commit the murder well, whatever
I'm gonna say is
My desire to make you think I didn't do the murder
So there's an there's a reason why I'm saying that line I didn't do it. I was at the movies
saying at the movies position
But it's connected to my desire to convince you that I was not the killer
You see so the exposition matches the objective of the character
you
know so there's ways to do this displaying it, you know, there's techniques to
Make sure the exposition is settled, you know part of a part of conflict part of your desire line, etc
There's a lot of stuff you could do, but that's the lesson you really have to know
That's the that's the most important thing make sure you know what every character once in the scene. Make sure that what they say
matches that objective so I
always bring out David Mamet was you know genius at dialogue and
he said once
Nobody says anything
Unless they want something
So unless you want something nobody says anything because nobody's gonna say, you know, hey
I'm a trustworthy character
Right, I mean if somebody said that to you you're not gonna you gonna be thinking whoa, why is he telling me this right?
there's always a reason why so there's always a reason and if we know what the reason is in the movie if you know what
The character wants or you're trying to figure out what the character want. That's more interesting then
Somebody dumping exposition, you know characters would just dump exposition
It's just boring because it's not it's not connected to a desire line even characters who disagree with each other
Even though that might be kind of interesting because there's some tension there
If if we don't know what they want, it's gonna be boring
So you see you see this a lot with amateur scenes of people like oh I need a conflict
So my characters are just gonna argue and so you have the people arguing back and forth, but it doesn't doesn't mean anything
It's just right because we don't know what they want. That's really what makes something interesting is
intention and
obstacle to that
On-the-nose dialogue could be one of the worst
I
Like to say sometimes that Talking Heads
dialogue where it's just two characters talking to each other kind of add each other and
Then Q&A sessions are the worst and that's where one character keeps asking another questions and then they just keep answering it
So it's almost like an interview and if that goes on for too long
It really tires out the reader and it just gets really what we minoes
It makes Crips awful is when characters tell you everything so
Examples are
If a husband and a wife, let's say a wife saw her husband
having lunch with another woman that
She didn't know about and he comes home from work. He's like hi, honey. How's your day? And
She were to say
What she'll probably say in real life is it nothing?
with that kind of you know, I mean Matthew waters a master of the
subtext I
Recommend looking at just about any episode of Mad Men, but much less interesting
so or she might say that the husband comes in and says
What did you do today?
and I was in a similar situation once with and I did not say I
Saw you with another woman having lunch today. I wanted him to like I wanted to maybe catch him in a lie. I
said or
actually, like well, I
You know, what did she do today? And he said nothing special really? Did you have lunch somewhere interesting?
What are you talking about
and like maybe
one of the things that I loved is that if you really
Play along with that. You can also play with the audience in terms of them thinking
Oh, yeah, he was having an affair then we find out that it was
an
interior decorator and
he was surprising his wife by he just bought a
little vacation home and
He was making sure that or you just like was renting in Malibu a place and he wanted to make sure all this stuff was
special for their anniversary and then what can happen is if she keeps testing him and testing him and and she like
starts bringing up old stuff about how he pisses her off that
scene could end with
Him not telling her what the surprise was and the couple deciding you never trust me
You know what? I was gonna do something nice with for you and screw you. I want a divorce
I'm just the spinning here, and I'm not saying that that's
You know
They the greatest scene
But that's an example of when you play with subtext versus characters
Saying everything that they're thinking another example if you take streetcar named desire
with Blanche and Stanley and Stella and if you had Blanche saying
well, I
Really have been working as a prostitute and I'm depressed and I have nowhere else to live
Game over like not very interesting. So if you think about it in those terms
Yeah, it's
And it's really reflecting how people are in real life
People don't always say exactly what they're thinking and feeling you find that when you start writing dialogues
Sometimes the characters talk differently than you then you'd expect that
Evolves, you know and that and that can be very interesting and sometimes your character changes as a result of your dialogue
But by and large, you know that you know, it's we're using our voices. We're using voices of people
We know we're using Cadence's we're using regional, you know words
You know, it's it's a combination of a lot of things but it does in a way it does write itself
You know, you're you're the driver but you know, it does kind of roll out
But again a dialogue, you know, it's about how do you write natural dialogue
How do you how do you write the way people really speak and it's cadence and it's it's it's simplicity of words. It's it's
You know expressing
saying the most imagine that the most amount of ideas and the least amount of
Letters basically at least amount of words and to keep it all moving forward. There's this thing like a bumper sticker
Actually, I don't call it
Pat Patrick Shane Duncan who wrote courage under fire and mr. Holland's opus calls it bumper sticker dialogue and
So what it is is it's he wrote
He did some rewrite work on a Chuck Norris movie and he didn't get credit
on-screen but everyone has the bumper sticker that says if I want your opinion
I beat it out of you and he wrote that line
And so if you come up with those lines go go ahead make my day, you know and all those things
That'll end up on a bumper sticker or a t-shirt. You know. Those are the gold we're looking for and
In the film noir class. I did out of the past just has a line after line after line you go
you could engrave that on a bar of gold and it would increase the value and
you know if we can come up those lines that are clever that people remember